aujourd'hui on va parler de deux images
choisies par raphaëlle branche et grâce
à son travail
on va voir comment la torture a peut
être une violence ordonné parfois même
réalisé avec un sentiment d'impunité
[Musique]
ces photos ont été prises pendant la
guerre d'algérie par jean philippe
charbonnier
elles sont des témoignages terrifiant de
la pratique de la torture par l'armée
française
les visages ont été floutés et la
seconde photo qui aurait dû être un
carré comme la première a été recadrée
mais les images restent clairs tout dit
que le photographe était le bienvenu
pour faire ces photos le cadrage sa
place dans la pièce la qualité des
photos et même simplement le fait qu'il
soit présent d'ailleurs ce sont les
militaires eux-mêmes ivre qui lui ont
demandé de venir immortaliser ces scènes
d'interrogations et de torture sur la
seconde photo que même les voir prendre
fièrement la pause pour des raisons
d'anonymat le floutage a été rajouté
après par les ayants droit du
photographe à l'occasion des expositions
où ont été présentés les photos ce qui
contredit totalement la volonté des
militaires d'être pris en photo
aujourd'hui il serait probablement
difficile d'avouer avoir participé à ce
genre de scène c'est un floutage qui
témoigne d'une nouvelle sensibilité
vis-à-vis de la violence ce qu'il faut
comprendre ce que pour certains soldats
c'est un spectacle et pour le
photographe
il est à mettre en scène car il fait un
travail de documentation qui sert à la
postérité
quand la photo est prise en 1957 le but
est de maintenir l'algérie française
les militaires français luttent contre
les indépendantistes du front de
libération nationale et il arrête toutes
les personnes qui leur paraissent
suspectes et dans certains régiments la
pratique de la torture est totalement
banalisé ici on voit très bien la
dimension coloniale de la guerre l'homme
arrêté n'est pas habillé comme un
combattant et les mêmes pieds nus on
peut comprendre que c'est un civil
raphaëlle branche note autre chose les
séances de torture était toujours fait
par un groupe de militaires dans lequel
chacun avait une place précise ici on
reconnaît le secrétaire qui notent les
renseignements celui qui tient le
prisonnier ou encore l'officier qui
interroge c'est toujours lui qui
commande et ordonne les tortures la
photo suivante est situé après les
victimes de torture était toujours mise
à nu avant d'être frappé la méthode de
torture la plus utilisée et l
électricité mais ici l'homme est mis à
la broche comme un animal on nie
totalement son humanité souvent une
salle était réservé à la torture un peu
à l'écart des autres pièces à cause du
bruit mais l'activité était souvent
banalisé et on peut deviner que c'est le
cas ici
les militaires donnent l'impression
qu'ils sont habitués les murs sont
recouverts de photos de pin up
le lieu est visiblement familier
régulièrement fréquenté ce ne sont pas
des photos volées et c'est important car
elle révèle un certain sentiment
d'impunité de la part du groupe de
militaires sont des photos composer avec
un éclairage soigné et un très beau
grand et c'est exactement pour ça
qu'elles sont troublantes
elle rappelle que pour certains la
violence peut être un spectacle
esthétique et une jouissance si ces deux
images ont été montrées dans une
exposition grand public en 2012
aujourd'hui on voit que la première on a
nous même hésité à faire pareil mais
quelque part la seconde donne à la
première tout son sens merci à raphaëlle
branche qui nous a permis de faire cette
vidéo et à bientôt sur une image une
histoire